♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT," THIS
EVENING WE WANT TO TELL YOU A
STORY ABOUT COLLUSION, ACTUAL
COLLUSION THAT'S CURRENTLY IN
PROGRESS.
THERE ARE NO SHADOWY HACKERS OR
IMAGINARY RENDEZVOUS' IN PRAGUE
IN THIS STORY, THERE'S NOT A
SINGLE RUSSIAN SPY OR SECRET SEX
TAPE, THERE'S NOTHING SHADOWY
ABOUT THE COLLUSION WERE GOING
TO TELL YOU ABOUT THE TAKES
PLACE IN THE OPEN ON LIVE
TELEVISION.
THIS IS A STORY ABOUT WHERE YOUR
NEWS COMES FROM.
THIS PAST SUNDAY WE LEARNED THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN DID NOT COLLUDE
WITH THE GOVERNMENT OF RUSSIA,
THE INVESTIGATION SPENT TWO
YEARS EXHAUSTIVELY LOOKING INTO
THE QUESTION.
THIS IS GOOD NEWS FOR AMERICA,
WE DON'T HAVE A SPY IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
BUT IT WAS APOCALYPTIC FOR THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND THE PRESS
AGENTS IN THE NEWS MEDIA.
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO WOULD STAKE
THEIR REPUTATIONS AND FORTUNES
ON THE COLLUSION HOAX AND THEY
WERE STUNNED.
BEFUDDLED POLITICIANS TRIED TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT TO SAY ABOUT THE
NEWS, VIEWERS OF LIBERAL MEDIA
OUTLETS DIDN'T WANT TO HEAR
ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
HUGE NUMBERS OF THEM QUIT
WATCHING IMMEDIATELY.
LAST NIGHT, CNN'S 8:00 P.M. SHOW
LOST NEARLY 50% OF ITS VIEWERS.
FOR PROGRESSIVE CHANNELS, THIS
WAS A CATASTROPHE, SOMETHING HAD
TO BE DONE.
INTO THIS DISASTER STEPPED THE
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE
NANCY PELOSI.
ON MONDAY JUST HOURS AFTER THE
COLLUSION STORY COLLAPSED, SHE
ANNOUNCED THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
WOULD BE SWITCHING GEARS.
GOING FORWARD, DEMOCRATS WOULD
FOCUS INTENTLY ON HEALTH CARE
JUST LIKE SHE DISINGENUOUSLY
CLAIMED THEY ALWAYS HAVE.
>> HAVE REPUBLICANS HELPED THE
DEMOCRATS SHIFT THE FOCUS?
>> WE'VE NEVER TAKEN OUR FOCUS
AWAY.
I HOPE IT FOCUSES THE PRESS ON
THESE ISSUES.
>> Tucker: I HOPE THE PRESS
FOCUSES ON HEALTH CARE -- AND
SHE DIDN'T HAVE TO ASK TWICE.
AT CNN THEY WERE PAYING CLOSE
ATTENTION TO EVERY WORD SHE
UTTERED.
TO JEFF ZUCKER AND THE ANCHORS
WHO WORK WITH HIM, SHE ISN'T
JUST A POLITICIAN, SHE IS THE
LEADER OF THE PARTY.
THERE PARTY.
THE PARTY UNDER WHOSE BANNER
ZUCKER SAID HE MAY SOMEDAY RUN
FOR OFFICE.
WHEN AMERICA'S MOST POWERFUL
DEMOCRAT SPEAKS, CNN LISTENS
WITH PEN IN HAND, THESE ARE
MARCHING ORDERS.
THE NETWORK SWUNG INTO ACTION
IMMEDIATELY.
THE RUNDOWN'S OF EVERY PRIME
TIME SHOW WERE SCRAPPED AND
REBUILT.
IF GONE WITH THE SEGMENTS ABOUT
OFFICE TOWERS IN MOSCOW AND
CARTER PAGE SPYING AND NONJUNIOR
GOING TO PRISON.
IN THEIR PLACE COME ALONG
EDITORIALS ABOUT HEALTH CARE.
THE HEALTH CARE PLAN IS SENSIBLE
AND NECESSARY, THE REPUBLICAN
PLAN CRUEL AND HEARTLESS.
BETWEEN 7:00 P.M. AND MIDNIGHT
LAST NIGHT, EVERY SHOW ON CNN
FOLLOWED NANCY PELOSI'S
INSTRUCTION, EVERY SINGLE SHOW
TALK ABOUT HEALTH CARE AND EVERY
SINGLE ONE THAT CHANNELED
NANCY PELOSI'S VIEWS ON
HEALTH CARE.
SHE COULD HAVE BEEN WRITING THE
SCRIPTS, MAYBE SHE WAS.
NOBODY HIT THAT TOPIC HARDER
THAN AN ANCHOR CALLED QUEST
PROMO.
HE'S THE SON OF THE FORMER
DEMOCRATIC GOVERNOR OF NEW YORK
AND THE BROTHER OF THE CURRENT
DEMOCRATIC GOVERNOR OF NEW YORK.
HIS INSTINCTS ARE SO OBVIOUSLY
POLITICAL.
LAST NIGHT THE GOVERNOR'S
BROTHER MET HIS TALKING POINTS
AS IF OFF A CUE CARD.
CLOSE YOUR EYES AS WE PLAY THIS
AND IMAGINE YOU ARE LISTENING TO
A 32ND ATTACK AD ON THE RADIO
DURING CAMPAIGN SEASON, SEE IF
YOU CAN TELL THE DIFFERENCE.
>> THE PRESIDENT SAID THE G.O.P.
WILL BE KNOWN AS THE PARTY OF
HEALTH CARE, IT SEEMS TO ME HE
LEFT OUT A WORD BASED ON HIS
ADMINISTRATION'S LATEST MOVE
WITH THE ACA.
PRESIDENT WILL MAKE HIS PARTY
ABOUT REMOVING HEALTH CARE.
THIS PRESIDENT AND HIS PARTY
HAVE NO PLAN TO PROVIDE CARE TO
TENS OF MILLIONS IF THE ACA IS
GONE, WHY?
WELCOME TO THE NEW NORMAL.
>> Tucker: THEY ARE TAKING
YOUR HEALTH CARE AWAY!
IF YOU'RE WAITING TO HEAR FOR
THE "PAID FOR BY THE KAMALA
HARRIS FOR PRESIDENT CAMPAIGN"
THEY LET IT OUT.
DON LEMON ISN'T NEARLY AS
POLITICAL AS THE GOVERNOR'S
BROTHER IS, HE'S THE LOCAL NEWS
GUY AT HEART -- THE FORMER
WEEKEND ANCHOR AT A STATION IN
BIRMINGHAM.
HE HAS A VERY SWEET GANG AND HE
KNOWS IT.
WHEN JEFF ZUCKER CAUSE AND TELLS
HIM TO TALK ABOUT HEALTH CARE,
HE DOES.
>> WHY IS HIS JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
SAYING THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT
SHOULD BE STRUCK DOWN?
THE PRESIDENT HAS SAID AGAIN AND
AGAIN HE WANTED TO PROTECT
PRE-EXISTING CONDITIONS, IS THIS
YET ANOTHER LIE FROM THE
PRESIDENT?
>> Tucker: YET ANOTHER LIE ON
HEALTH CARE!
AT NO POINT DID ANY OF THE
ANCHORS MENTION WHAT WAS SO
OBVIOUS.
THEY WENT FROM THE RUSSIA
CONSPIRACY NETWORK TO EXTEND AN
ADVERTISEMENT FOR THE AFFORDABLE
CARE ACT AS WRITTEN BY
BARACK OBAMA.
THE VIEWERS MUST HAVE WONDERED
WHAT WAS GOING ON.
WHERE'S MY SEGMENT ABOUT HOW
DON JR. IS GOING TO PRISON, I
WANT TO HEAR MORE ABOUT THAT.
BUT NO, ON NANCY PELOSI'S ORDERS
IT WAS HEALTH CARE WEEK, THEY
WERE BACK AT IT THIS MORNING,
STARTING AT 6:00 A.M. EVERY
SINGLE SHOW ON CNN'S MORNING
LINEUP ALL THROUGH THE DAY
REGURGITATED HER TALKING POINTS
TO THE WORD ABOUT HEALTH CARE.
REPUBLICANS WILL MAKE YOU SICK,
ONLY DEMOCRATS WILL MAKE YOU
WELL.
EVERY SINGLE SHOW MADE THAT
POINT.
IF YOU WERE STUCK IN THE AIRPORT
IT WAS LIKE LIVING IN
NORTH KOREA, A SPEAKER BOLTED TO
THE WALL ABOVE YOUR HEAD BLARING
AN ENDLESS LOOP OF PROPAGANDA
YOU CAN'T TURN OFF.
>> HOUSE SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI
AND CONGRESSIONAL DEMOCRATS,
JUST THE OPENING THEY NEEDED TO.
>> IT PUTS HEALTH CARE AT SOME
LEVEL OF UNCERTAINTY AND ALSO
JEOPARDY.
>> WHAT WOULD HAPPEN, WHAT WOULD
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS LOSE?
>> JUST TO BE CLEAR, REPUBLICANS
DO NOT HAVE A PLAN TO REPLACE
OBAMACARE.
>> THE FATE OF HEALTH CARE FOR
NEARLY 20 MILLION AMERICANS
INSURED THROUGH OBAMACARE AND
MEDICAID EXPANSION HANGS IN THE
BALANCE.
>> AS OF THIS MOMENT,
REPUBLICANS HAVE NOT OFFERED A
SINGLE NEW ALTERNATIVE TO
OBAMACARE.
>> SOME PEOPLE CHARACTERIZING
THIS AS A GIFT TO NANCY PELOSI
GOING INTO THE NEXT 2020
ELECTION.
>> GET RID OF OBAMACARE SAYS THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION, WHAT'S THE
PLAN TO REPLACE IT -- WE DON'T
KNOW SAYS THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
>> SIMPLY REPEALING OBAMACARE
WITHOUT REPUBLICANS COALESCING
BEHIND AN ALTERNATIVE WOULD
THROW THE HEALTH CARE SYSTEM
INTO CHAOS.
>> THAT IS LAUGHABLE.
>> YOU READ MY MIND, I WANTED TO
GET YOUR RESPONSE TO THE
PRESIDENT SAYING WE WOULD HAVE A
PLAN.
LAUGHABLE, NOTED.
>> Tucker: LAUGHABLE.
WE HAVE NO IDEA WHAT THEY HAVE
BEEN SHOWING, WE HAD TO TURN IT
OFF AT 4:00 P.M.
IF WE HAD TO GUESS, HEALTH CARE.
WE HAVE A NEWS ALERT NOW,
ACCORDING TO OUR PRODUCERS WHO
ARE MONITORING THE SITUATION ON
CNN AND MSNBC THEY'RE TALKING
ABOUT HEALTH CARE, RIGHT NOW.
HEALTH CARE.
PELOSI'S ORDERS.
WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU?
IT TELLS YOU WHERE YOUR NEWS
COMES FROM.
DEMOCRATIC OFFICIALS PICK THE
TOPIC AND THE STORY LINE, THEIR
SERVANTS IN CABLE NEWS DUTIFULLY
REPEAT IT TO THE WORD ALL DAY
LONG.